the woman the terrorist
the villain who is also sometimes a man
and a freedom fighter and a hero
[Music]
hey there everybody so uh this is
something i've kind of wanted to do
for a while this sort of thing i'm going
to take a look at
mystique from x-men and examine her as
a queer icon now i want to be clear that
this is a case of me applying a queer
lens
to her and not so much limiting myself
to explicitly queer elements of her
character though we will be touching on
those
as we go along this is similar to when i
did my trans readings of
five famous films and how i am
applying that lens onto the character
and i am going to be reading
queerness into elements of her character
that may not be intended to be
interpreted that way
but still can be this is really
important with characters that have been
around for as long as mystique because
until relatively recently you had to
just accept characters that could be
read as queer that were coded as queer
because explicit queer representation
still isn't
in the best place but was almost
non-existent
for a very long time so it's nice to
look back at these characters
and the ways in which you could read
that into them
so here's a couple of bullet points
that you should know about mystique
mystique was created in 1978 by writer
chris claremont
and artist dave cockrum now cockrum
actually did the work first he
drew her just as something that he drew
and chris claremont saw the
design and said hey uh can i use her
and got clearance from cochran and then
she began appearing as a villain
in the ms marvel comic which
claremont was writing at the time so
that was the introduction of the
evil shapeshifter that is mystique as a
villain
for carol danvers now mystique would not
become associated with the x-men
until a little bit later and on her way
there she was also
the mentor to rogue yes if you did not
know
rogue was originally a villainous
character
stick a pin in that we'll come back to
her now over the years mystique would
take on a number of roles as
leaders of villainous teams as leaders
of
ostensibly heroic teams as a covert
operative
ostensibly acting heroically
and often working her own agenda always
in the back of her mind trying to push
mutant equality if not mutant
superiority
before we get too far into this i want
to make something explicitly queer
mystique
for all the things i am about to say
positive about her characterization
is not a good person especially in the
comics
you get into some other depictions it
gets a little grayer but
no she is an awful person she does some
awful things
so i ain't defending any of that
just take it as red so let's talk about
actually applying a queer reading to
this character well
she is effectively a mutant activist
an extremist one could argue certainly
in tactic
if not uh ultimate goal but
there's more to it than that there's her
power
that of shape-shifting shape-shifting
is the kind of deceitful thing that you
would often see given to
femme fatale female villains who
aren't you know powered up to punch and
deal damage
along with the guys often they are in
some way sneaky or duplicitous so
shape-shifting fits into that but
shape-shifting also fits into
a queer reading of the character for a
number of reasons
firstly if anyone with a
non-standard gender identity so speaking
personally
gender fluid my sense of self doesn't
stay put
it moves around it shifts my
presentation
varies as does hers and despite the fact
that her
normal appearance gives her away
immediately as a mutant she has the
ability
to be undercover she can
pass for a human
the way many gay
lesbian pansexual bisexual people can if
they choose
pass for straight and the way many trans
people
wish to pass as the gender they identify
as
mystique can just do it that is power
fantasy yet at the same time
there's a bitter sweetness to that
because yes she can passes these things
but they are not
who she is they're not true
to her just like
a straight bi gay pansexual
asexual person pretending to be
heterosexual
they're not being true to themselves or
if a trans person
either because of circumstance or safety
or
just lack of support
continues to pass for the gender that
they were assigned to birth
even though that's not accurate but if
we're really going to dig into the queer
elements of this character
we got to talk about her key
relationships
without even getting into adopted kids
which would include rogue again
keep a hold of that pin we'll come back
to it she has had
four sons night crawler grading creed
rey's dark home and charles xavier ii
now those latter two i'm not really
gonna deal with partly because
they are more recent editions and i
don't really know a lot about what the
deal is with
either of them but let's dig into
the other two a little bit why don't we
actually start with grade and creed
because with grey and creed we deal with
something that
can happen for many queer people
and that is familial rejection
usually that comes in the form of
parents rejecting their children which
is something
that x-men in various incarnations
in terms of be it the movies the
cartoons the comics
has dealt with but this
deals with something a little bit more
specific that isn't
talked about as often but does
happen which is being rejected by
your children it's not talked about as
much but those who come out or
transition later in life
face the possibility of being rejected
by their adult children
now to be fair
misty did completely abandon him as soon
as she realized he was a normal human
not a mutant so she was not exactly
gunning for mother of the year
but graydon took that hatred
of his parents his father was a
sabertooth for the record
spread it out to all of mutant kind
which again is very indicative
oftentimes
of how hate can happen
when you have a
bad experience with someone who is a
member
of some kind of minority if you
don't have other positive experiences
with that minority to counter balance
that
you can apply the pain caused by that
one person
across the entire group which is exactly
what grade and cream did
now there's also night crawler now
officially what did happen
is that mystique is nightcrawler's
mother he is the offspring of her and a
demon called a zazel
that was not the original intent
for nightcrawler's parentage
originally what chris claremont wanted
to do
he never got the chance to now the
reason he didn't get to do what i'm
about to tell you
it is difficult to pin down it may have
been officially rejected
by the people at marvel but he was also
moved around
which books he was working on and he
might simply have been moved off of
x-men before he had the chance to
execute it
it's not 100 clear but it is
clear that what he wanted was for a
night crawler
to still be mystique's son but mystique
wasn't going to be his mother
mystique was going to be his father
and what was supposed to happen chris
claremont's original intent
brilliant mad man that he is
was to have nightcrawler
be the offspring of mystique and destiny
and we need to talk about destiny
destiny was a precognitive
mutant and she was
very close with mystique and
during the time that they were both
active in the comics
that was not permitted to be shown as
explicitly
romantic it was implied
heavily but never explicitly stated as
being anything other than a
deeply personal friendship
but it was more than that and chris
claremontes confirmed that it was always
his intent
that it was going to be more than that
and that
his intention was for misty to use her
shape-shifting abilities
to become male and as a man
impregnate destiny with nightcrawler
and while as i said unfortunately that
did not get to happen the romantic and
sexual nature
of the relationship between mystique and
destiny
has been explicit since 2019 which
that year was the 30th anniversary of
destiny's death
she died in 1989
and has not come back to life we've had
flashbacks which is
how we got the confirmation but she's
remained deceased
and i kind of expect that she will
continue to be
deceased because comics have a severe
aversion to people being in
happy relationships but i
also want to share one wonderful
beautiful moment that happened between
these two characters
and this happened while the character
was still alive
and this was overseen by chris claremont
there is a scene in which
mystique takes on a masculine presenting
form
so that she and destiny
can dance together in a public space
and not attract attention she's willing
to present
however she has to so that the two of
them can have that moment together and
not
have to hide away mystique is still
hiding in a way
but the two of them are in public
together showing their affection sharing
this moment
and it is mystique's ability to shift
between
appearance and genders that allows that
moment to happen
you remember that pin that we went and
stuck into the subject of rogue
well why don't we take that out and talk
about her real quick there's a couple of
things going on with rogue the first is
she is effectively the adopted daughter
of
mystique and destiny that alone already
lends itself to a certain amount of
queer reading because
many queer couples adopt either by
choice or in some cases because
it's really the only way they're going
to have children and as far as how they
quote unquote raised her they brought
her up in their
world view and prepared her to fight
back at the world outside
granted they also taught her to rob and
to steal and to
be a villain but again mystique not a
good
person and finally one last note
something that i kind of take amusement
from
you may have noticed rogue back then
didn't look like she does now in fact
she looked borderline androgynous which
to me
just feels all the more fitting for
someone raised by a queer couple with a
very nebulous sense of gender at least
when it comes to mystique
so that's mystique's origins her power
her i would argue most important
relationship in her life
so now why don't we take a look at
mystique's queerness
through the lens of her political and
activist
activities well there's a few things
that are definitely
standouts from this particular angle now
obviously she was introduced flat out as
a villain and as i stated at the front
it should never be forgotten she is not
a good person
however she is a very active
activist for mutants some would argue
terrorist but here's some of the stuff
that she has done
to further the cause of the rights of
her people
we have the reformation of the
brotherhood of evil mutants
originally created by magneto that group
had completely disbanded
she reformed it she brought it back now
some might ask why would you
call it the brotherhood of evil mutants
something she would later claim was
being done
in irony because that's how humans were
gonna
perceive them anyways now when i
mentioned that mystique is actually
quite politically savvy
something that a lot of folks who
haven't been long-time readers of the
character might not realize
she worked for the government for a
while there was a period of time
where the brotherhood of evil mutants
was under the employee of the u.s
government renamed freedom force
and she went along with that because she
saw the political advantage of
allying herself with the entity that was
well had the power to either help or
hinder her cause
now if we're going to talk queer
readings about her actions and
motivations
this is the point where i have to bring
up
that line from x2
when nightcrawlers talking to her
establishes that she can
hide herself completely completely
change her physical appearance and even
the voice that she uses and he asks her
why don't you always hide why don't you
always look like everyone else
and she gives the perfect response
because we shouldn't have to
now broadly speaking the x-men movies
especially
those first few leaned much more heavily
into
the idea of x-men and mutants as an
allegory for queer identities
specifically as opposed to the
broader possible interpretations that it
could have which is usually how the
comics
have done it and that is very much
a queer statement because
most queer people not all but most
have the ability to be in the closet
they can pass for straight
they can pass as a
gender either the one that they were
born as or some could even pass as the
gender that they transition into
but the thing is they shouldn't have to
hide
even if they can that's a statement of
purpose
that is queer pride and the reason
for queer activism in a nutshell
taking that political savviness and who
she aligns herself with in a slightly
darker direction particularly if i'm
going to give it a queer reading
there was a period of time in which she
was effectively a double agent for
professor xavier
she did the dirty work that he knew
needed to be done
but he could not risk the x-men doing he
could not
risk their images being tainted
by what he needed done and so he got
mystique to do it someone who is
the much more publicly accepted head
of the mutants so if we extrapolate and
say
the queer movement uses her
uses her in a way that is to his
advantage
but he will not be there to support her
he expects her support of him
but he is not going to reciprocate that
and i think if i could get dark
for a little bit that feels in many ways
reflective of some of the
infighting that goes on within the lgbtq
plus community
and if you're outside this community you
might not be aware of it but
it's not a homogeneous group there are
people in various stripes of
this rainbow that we exist in
who take issue with others
and it's not that huge a leap to
interpret
the acts of charles xavier under the
circumstances to be
along the lines of people who are
pushing forward a
say for instance homosexual
positive platform but are not prepared
to fight for trans rights
but they can still expect trans people
to support them because
that is adjacent to what trans people
hope to accomplish and
they need to see some progress somewhere
if they're ever going to have a hope
but they are still going to get left
behind in that scenario
and so is mystique by charles comic
books and comic book characters like
mystique have the ability to do
so much they can inspire us
they can terrify us they can give us
something
to aspire to or something to avoid ever
becoming but they can also just be
ridiculously fun and if you're looking
for a comic that
is just flat out fun maybe you should
consider looking today's sponsor
renard city is a comic that features
wonderfully over-the-top characters both
heroes and villains
taking place in a fun inventive world
and
all with a vibe of a saturday morning
cartoon from the 80s or 90s
ridiculous but absolutely shameless
about the fact
that it is ridiculous it follows the
adventures of animal kingdom girl
or ak girl who has a ton of powers
and one notable weakness she
inflates like a balloon if she comes
into contact with caramel
yeah that should give you an idea of the
vibe of this thing
tongue is planted firmly in cheek and it
just
runs with that vibe and if what you're
seeing and what i'm
telling you seems at all interesting to
you well
you don't even have to pay to read it
go to renardcitychronicles.com and you
can read
issues for free it is a web comic
although
if you do really like it you can receive
physical copies of certain issues
as well so you can support it if you
really do like it that much
and find out whether or not you like it
that much
go to the site bernardcitychronicles.com
give it a look have fun and i do
especially want to thank
rob turner a writer for that comic for
his support for quite a while and for
sponsoring this video
that'll wrap it up for this one folks
now i would like to do something like
this in the future but
i'm not sure who else to cover in this
manner off the top of my head
mystique was top of my list because
mystique was a massive inspiration
for me in terms of a character that i
read as queer and who thankfully later
got confirmed
to be but who are some of your
queer icons who are the characters from
comics cartoons
tv movies that you really latched on to
for embodying a sense of queerness that
spoke to you
whatever they are however they spoke to
you drop something down the comments
let's talk about it i do have a patreon
if you are interested in helping me out
and keeping this channel
going and ensuring that i can eat and
things like that
uh plus i've got a whole other bunch of
things there's links to
merch and other social media and things
like that and
even if you're not up for or able to
spend money
just things like liking sharing
subscribing
hitting that bell all of those help me
out as well
so thank you very much for tuning in and
actually
you don't have to do any of those things
like
i'd appreciate it i really would but
end of the day you're the council
i just run the meetings and until next
time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]